Росія заявляє, що захопила Луганську область на сході України.
Також Москва посилює удари по житловим будинкам і торгівельним центрам. Зростають жертви серед цивільного населення і втрати серед військових.
Україна програЄ цю війну?
Зовсім ні.
Так вважає мій гість - Курт Волкер - у минулому посол США в НАТО і спецпредставник Держдепартаменту з питань України.
На його думку, Захід повинен робити більше для підтримки України.
Пам’ятайте, що українці платять за нашу безпеку своїм життям. Тож ми мали б заплатити за їхню безпеку зі своєї кишені.
Чи похитнеться єдність Заходу у підтримці України?
Про це і не тільки  у програмі "Зона конфлікту".
Пане Волкере, ласкаво просимо до "Зони конфлікту".
Дякую, радий приєднатися.
Минулого тижня відбувся саміт НАТО, на якому альянс назвав Росію прямою загрозою для блоку. Як це допоможе Україні?
По-перше, на мою думку, НАТО необхідно виконувати своє основне завдання, тобто забезпечувати колективну оборону.
Тому визнання російської загрози не тільки для України, а і для Європи в цілому, - це важливий крок для НАТО.
Це дозволить альянсу вдосконалювати власну оборону, збільшити витрати на неї, підготувати сили швидкого реагування,
розгортати угруповання на більшій території. Мета таких дій - стримання Росії.
Конкретно для України це не допомога. І все ж, деякі союзники по НАТО, зокрема, США, Німеччина, Великобританія, надають пряму допомогу Україні.
Але це робиться поза рамками НАТО.
В нещодавньому інтерв’ю ви зазначили, що НАТО добре подбало про захист блоку. Щойно ви це підтвердили.
Але коли справа доходить до реагування на найбільшу в Європі війну, то, цитую вас: "НАТО не проявило себе". Пане Волкере, НАТО "здає" Україну?
Я думаю, що НАТО зараз не відіграє ролі в цій найбільшій війні в Європі. НАТО було засноване для безпеки союзників, і воно цим займається.
Але в стратегічній концепції організації, зокрема і в тій, яку погодили нещодавно на Мадридському саміті,
зазначено, що друге основне завдання альянсу - це кризовий менеджмент.
А НАТО нині не задіяне по-справжньому у врегулювання кризи, війни Росії проти України.
На мою думку, сьогодні НАТО могло би бути принаймні координаційним центром для поставок зброї в Україну.
Сполучені Штати надають озброєння з авіабази Рамштайн, координують поставки на двосторонній основі з іншими країнами. Це могло б робити і НАТО.
Що ще НАТО мало б зробити? Ідеться лише про функцію координаційного центру
чи НАТО могло б зробити щось більше, аби безпосередньо допомогти Україні?
Так, гадаю, НАТО могло б також збирати розвіддані та обмінюватися ними з Україною, тобто виконувати комунікаційні функції.
І ще важливіше, як на мене, - тренувати та обмундировувати українських військових.
НАТО могло б це робити, але наразі це роблять лише окремі союзники.
Поговорімо про те, як швидко виграти цю війну. Президент України Зеленський уже кілька місяців вимагає від Заходу далекобійну артилерію.
Також, за його словами, Україна потребує 5 мільярдів доларів щомісяця. Чи отримає він те, що просить?
Він уже отримує дещо, про що він просить, але не все.
Американські ракетні комплекси HIMARS уже доставили в Україну, їх інтегрують у Збройні сили України.
Вони вже допомогли українським військовим завдати ударів по деяких російських складах боєприпасів, наприклад, на аеродромі Мелітополя.
Тож, це важливо. Україна також отримає більш складні системи ППО, які мають допомогти захистити міста від ракетних ударів.
Але президент Зеленський говорить, що ці поставки надто повільні. Чи зміниться це?
На жаль, я не бачу жодних змін. Я згоден з президентом Зеленським. Він не отримує стільки, скільки йому потрібно.
Йому треба в рази більше зброї - десятки реактивних систем залпового вогню, артилерійські системи.
Україна отримує їх значно менше і повільніше, ніж, я думаю, усім нам хотілося б.
Чому так відбувається? Тому, що НАТО зволікає? Чи тому, що немає запасів, аби надати їх на запит України?
Знову ж таки, цим займається не НАТО, а окремі країни блоку, зокрема США.
Німеччина, наскільки я знаю, має дуже обмежені запаси, інші країни НАТО також мають обмаль зброї.
США постачають Україні озброєння за рахунок скорочення власних запасів, але все одно це займає багато часу.
Щодо реактивних систем залпового вогню, артилерії великої дальності - ще в лютому та березні ми знали, що вони знадобляться.
А зараз липень, і такі озброєння тільки прибувають в Україну. У цьому питанні можна було б діяти набагато швидше.
ПоговорІмо про перебіг війни. ООН зафіксувала понад 10 000 жертв серед цивільного населення в Україні.
Близько 12 мільйонів людей були змушені покинути свої домівки. Минулими вихідними Росія заявила, що контролює Луганську область.
Україна програЄ цю війну?
Зовсім ні. Росія розв'язала війну, щоб відновити Російську імперію, знищити українську державність і народ. Їм це не вдалося.
Українці відтіснили росіян з півночі, від Києва, Харкова, Сум, Чернігова, Одеси.
Отже, Україна довела, що залишатиметься суверенною, незалежною європейською демократією. Це критично важливо.
Росія захопила приблизно п'яту частину території України, але заплатила за це високу ціну.
Ймовірно, вони зараз не зможуть продовжити наступ і намагатимуться окопатися та організувати оборону...
Але я думаю, що питання, пане Волкере, полягає в тому, що буде з цією п'ятою частиною території України?
Евріл Гейнс, директорка Національної розвідки США, підтвердила, що Росія контролює близько 20 відсотків України.
Водночас президент Зеленський стверджує, що Україна поверне всі свої території. Це взагалі реально?
Це реально. Це амбітно, але реально. Українці виснажили російську армію, Росія не захоплює нові території, наступ зупинився.
Україна почне контрнаступ, щоб повернути території. Українці діятимуть більш стратегічно, ніж росіяни.
Захоплення Росією Луганщини не має особливого військового значення.
Українці спочатку спробують вибити росіян з Херсона -  переріжуть маршрути поставок, відтіснять росіян,
переріжуть сухопутне сполучення між Донбасом і Кримом, імовірно, в районі Мелітополя.
Також Україна намагатиметься відтіснити росіян від Харкова. Усе це, на мою думку, цілком досяжне.
Наскільки далеко українці зможуть вибити росіян, ми ще не знаємо, але вони точно налаштовані боротися.
Багато що зрештою залежатиме від переговорів.
Саме з цього приводу я хотів би звернути вашу увагу на нещодавню статтю у виданні The Telegraph, яку написали міністр закордонних справ України
Дмитро Кулеба разом зі своєю британською колегою Ліз Трасс.
Цитую: "Путін серйозно сприйматиме переговори лише тоді, коли українці відкинуть його війська".
Думаю, ви згодні, що це не буде швидко й легко. Чи є ризик, що західним партнерам України не вистачить на це терпіння?
Ризик є. Час від часу ми чуємо заяви на кшталт "ми не повинні принижувати Путіна" - здається, так говорив президент Макрон.
Або що Україні потрібно сідати за стіл переговорів, бо вона несе надто великі втрати.
Але щоразу українці нагадують, що йдеться про їхню країну, і вони будуть вирішувати, відвойовувати її чи ні.
Вони налаштовані на боротьбу. Поки українці зберігають цю рішучість, я майже впевнений, що Захід і Сполучені Штати продовжать підтримувати Україну.
Ви згадали заяву президента Макрона, за яку його критикували в Україні.
Також згадаймо мирний план Італії, який, по суті, пропонує зробити Донбас і Крим предметом переговорів між Росією та Україною.
На вашу думку, чи існує ризик того, що багатші країни Європи, такі як Німеччина, Франція, Італія,
будуть наполягати на припиненні вогню навіть за рахунок здачі українських територій?
Так, я думаю, що такий ризик є. Мирний план Італії, коментарі Макрона, деякі заяви з Німеччини це підтверджують.
До того ж Путін спробує скоротити постачання газу до Європи цієї зими.
Він сподівається в такий спосіб змусити Західну Європу підштовхнути Україну до здачі територій.
Це підло з боку Путіна, але він має такі наміри.
Важливо, щоб усі ми продовжували підтримувати Україну, чинити тиск на Росію і не піддавалися закликам до України поступитися територією.
Як розвиватимуться події, якщо під час переговорів Україна вимагатиме того, чого її західні прихильники не зможуть надати?
Складно сказати, тому що нині західні країни постійно підкреслюють свою підтримку суверенітету,
територіальної цілісності і права України повернути свої території.
Тому немає нічого такого, про що Україна могла б попросити й не отримати принципової підтримки Заходу.
ПоговорІмо про Захід в цілому. Ви були послом США в НАТО, тож хотілося б поговорити про роль Сполучених Штатів у цій війні.
Поки що громадськість у США підтримує зусилля уряду з допомоги Україні.
Але враховуючи деякі суперечливі внутрішні проблеми, які зараз виходять на перший план у США, як довго громадська думка залишатиметься такою?
Щодо Сполучених Штатів, на мою думку, вони не тільки дотримуватимуться нинішнього курсу, а й посилять підтримку.
Адміністрація Байдена діяла повільно, робила часткові кроки та зазнавала тиску з боку Конгресу -
і республіканців, і демократів, які вимагали діяти швидше і рішучіше.
Цей тиск базється на потужній суспільній підтримці України у США.
Я вважаю, що проміжні вибори в листопаді зміцнять сили в Конгресі, які змушуватимуть адміністрацію Байдена робити ще більше для допомоги Україні.
Погляньмо на те, що відбувається у Європейському Союзі.
Міністерка закордонних справ Швеції Анн Лінде застерегла, що інтерес до війни в Україні згасає на тлі зростання цін на продукти та енергоносії.
Очікується, що ціни зростуть ще більше в кінці року. Борис Джонсон теж застерігає щодо "втоми від України".
Чи зможе Європа підтримувати Україну в довгостроковій перспективі?
Так, це виклик. Ми вже говорили про це. Я думаю, що Європі стане важче, оскільки Росія скорочуватиме поставки енергоносіїв цієї зими,
підвищуватиме ціни. І це спричинить серйозні проблеми в Європі, що у свою чергу може змусити європейські уряди сказати:
"Гаразд, час Україні сідати з стіл переговорів про припинення вогню". На мою думку, це найбільший ризик, з яким ми зараз стикаємося.
По суті, ви говорите про те, що російський газ може підірвати європейську єдність.
Таке вже траплялося в минулому і може повторитися.
Безумовно, Володимир Путін має намір використовувати енергетику таким чином.
Отже, коли генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг каже, що Україна матиме підтримку альянсу, цитую, "стільки, скільки буде потрібно" - ви йому вірите?
Так, вірю. Він робить правильні заяви. Я думаю, що зараз усі країни це підтримують.
Але враховуючи тенденції, які ми обговорювали, це може змінитися.
Ми маємо працювати над тим, щоб і в Сполучених Штатах, і в Європі, особливо взимку,
якщо буде енергетична криза, залишалася сила духу для підтримки України.
Пам’ятайте, що українці платять за нашу безпеку своїм життям. Тож ми мали б заплатити за їхню безпеку зі своєї кишені.
Ви також сказали в березні, що ключем до виживання України є стримання російських військ достатньо довго,
щоб санкції проти Росії почали діяти. Як ви вважаєте, санкції вже достатньо подіяли?
Ні, не достатньо, потрібно більше часу. Тиждень за тижнем ми бачимо деякі докази того, що санкції "кусаються".
Наприклад, акціонери "Газпрому" проголосували за збільшення суми податків, які вони платять російському уряду.
Це показник того, що російському уряду бракує грошей. Отже, є результати.
Але я вважаю, що нам потрібно закрити лазівки в санкціях, особливо проти менших російських банків,
які є прикриттям більших банків, проти фінансових переказів до Росії, які все ще проходять, і поставок нафти з Росії.
Варто припинити страхування російських суден, припинити імпорт російських нафти і газу.
Враховуючи нинішній стан Європейського Союзу, ви вважаєте це реалістичним?
Зупинити імпорт нафти можливо. Для цього я не бачу перешкод. Із газом складніше.
Люди розуміють, що відмовитися від нього буде складно, особливо цієї зими.
Але знову ж таки, українці платять за це своїми життями.
Ми повинні розуміти, що діяти треба терміново, навіть якщо ціни дещо зростуть.
На мою думку, Європа може відмовитися від російського газу раніше, ніж наприкінці наступного року, як це планується нині.
Погляньмо на майбутнє відносин між ЄС і Росією.
В інтерв’ю 27 червня, пане Волкере, ви сказали наступне:
"Європейці мають усвідомити, що ми більше не можемо жити по сусідству з цим геноцидним маніяком ".
Мабуть, ми з вами обидва погоджуємося, що Путін не піде з посади найближчим часом. Отже, як виглядає це майбутнє?
Неможливо мати справу з такими, як Путін. Він надіслав свої війська в Україну, почав загарбницьку війну.
Він не раз брехав про свої наміри.
Він скеровував свою армію на вчинення воєнних злочинів, а це використання зґвалтувань як зброї на війні,
вбивства цивільних осіб, удари по пологовим будинкам та цивільним об'єктам.
Європа більше не може співпрацювати з Путіним, його режиму доведеться піти.
Зважаючи на це, я не згоден з тим, що ми не скоро побачимо кінець Путіна.
Є багато ознак того, що у нього погано зі здоров’ям, і це навіть може бути однією з причин,
чому він зараз так наполегливо намагається загарбати українські території.
Він хоче, щоб це було частиною його особистого спадку.
Тиск на Росію посилюється, санкції діють, тож напруга всередині РФ може дійти апогею, ми маємо бути готові до цього.
Треба продовжувати тиснути на Росію.
Пане Волкере, що може зробити Європа, щоб ця війна припинилася і настав мир?
Потрібно, щоб Росія вивела свої війська з України. Це шлях до миру.
Якщо Росія матиме змогу нападати на своїх сусідів, захоплювати їхні території, здійснювати воєнні злочини і не нести за це відповідальності,
у Європі ніколи не буде миру. Нагадаю, Росія також окупувала частини Молдови та Грузії.
Тож те, що ми бачимо в Україні, є жорстоким продовженням багаторічної моделі поведінки.
Росія й далі так діятиме, якщо її не зупинити.
Пане Волкере, на цьому ми завершимо. Дякую за цю розмову.
Дякую вам.